y
[Música]
juramento el nuevo gobierno de israel
con lo que se terminan 12 años de
mandato de un jazmín detalla que el
nuevo ejecutivo está encabezado por el
derechista naftalí bennett y ya recibió
la felicitación de líderes como el
presidente de eeuu y la canciller de
alemania
netanyahu anunció que hará parte de la
oposición con la frente en alto tenemos
información desde tel aviv
finalizó la cumbre del g7 en cornualles
con las promesas de los líderes de donar
mil millones de vacunas contra el joven
19 a los países de menores ingresos
crear un mecanismo de detección temprana
de posibles pandemias cooperar en la
reactivación de economías y mayores
esfuerzos a favor del medio ambiente
tenemos informes desde hal map
la policía nicaragüense arrestó a otros
cuatro opositores tras acusarlos de
incitar a la injerencia extranjera y
pedir intervenciones militares contra el
gobierno de daniel ortega con estas con
estas detenciones ya son 12 los
capturados de cara a las elecciones del
7 de noviembre en las que ortega busca
su cuarta reelección
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france24 soy
valentina torre sánchez iniciamos este
informativo en israel donde juramentó el
nuevo gobierno tras recibir el voto de
confianza en la que meseta se trata del
fin de la era netanyahu que llevaba 12
años en el poder y ahora el gobierno
formado por una coalición extraordinaria
de 8 partidos estará liderado por el
ultranacionalista religioso en estelí
benet durante los dos primeros años por
su parte netanyahu aseguró que
conformará la oposición con la frente en
alto y resaltó entre sus logros
convertir al país en una potencia de
seguridad y tecnología para ampliar esta
noticia conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal entre la vida maya
simonovic vaya de su primera
intervención
bennett hizo un llamado a la unidad y la
reconciliación nacional pero como he
recibido el hecho de que un
ultranacionalista haga esta petición en
el país
me es difícil determinarlo porque es muy
prematuro todavía lo que parece es que
casi cualquier cosa que hubiera sacado a
netanyahu para el bloque del cambio este
este nuevo a esta nueva coalición
liderada por bennett y el lápiz que se
llama en el bloque del cambio casi
cualquier cosa que hubieran hecho
hubiera sido bienvenida porque el
espíritu nacional desde hace mucho
tiempo por lo menos de gran parte de la
población israelí es que querían que
fuera desalojada ya la residencia del
primer ministro por netanyahu y pedían
en cambio y sin embargo la mayoría por
él por la que ganó a este gobierno del
cambio fue muy muy muy raspadita en
hasta el último minuto no se supo si iba
a suceder o no iba a suceder y que
bennett a pelé a la unidad nacional en
la restauración es realmente algo que
parece ser que es el gran sentir de los
israelíes
hay mucho conflicto social el partido
perdón en la que en ese del parlamento
está dividido pero es un fiel reflejo de
la sociedad israelí que está dividida
también dividida y bastante furiosa como
se vio hoy antes de la votación antes
del voto de confianza del nuevo gobierno
de hugo mientras benet e intentaba dar
su discurso fue interrumpido en
múltiples ocasiones precisamente por
esta falta de coordinación maya muchas
gracias por esta información estamos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda ocurrir en
las próximas horas vamos ahora a reino
unido donde finalizó la cumbre del g7
tras tres días de encuentros
presenciales los líderes de los países
más industrializados se comprometieron a
responder a la pandemia enviando mil
millones de vacunas a las naciones de
menores ingresos a implementar un
mecanismo de detección temprana de
posibles pandemias a reactivar economías
aumentar los esfuerzos contra el cambio
climático y a financiar infraestructuras
en países de pocos recursos asimismo se
opusieron a las prácticas
anticompetitivas ya las violaciones de
los derechos humanos de china
a rusia que termine con sus
interferencias en otros países desde
nuestra enviada especial luisa pulido en
los amplia
la donación de mil millones de dosis de
vacunas para los países en desarrollo
que deben ser entregadas entre lo que
queda de este 2021 y el 2022 es el gran
anuncio de la cumbre del g7 que esta
tarde bajó su telón aquí en la costa
inglesa en colmar sin embargo aunque
este es un avance bien importante
proyecciones de la organización mundial
de la salud que estiman que se requieren
por son por lo menos 11 mil millones de
dosis para vacunar el 70 por ciento de
la población
de otro lado del g7 también se ha
comprometido con recursos para la
recuperación de la economía mundial para
crear nuevos puestos de trabajo para que
la economía sea más sostenible con el
medio ambiente y también prevenir
posibles nuevas pandemias invirtiendo en
ciencia teniendo presentes las alertas
tempranas para evitar que posibles
nuevas enfermedades se conviertan en
estas pandemias y también bajar a máximo
100 días el tiempo máximo para poder
desarrollar vacunas pero también el 17
se ha comprometido con
cursos para la educación de millones de
niños y de niñas en todo el mundo para
cortar con ese ciclo de pobreza también
el g7 se ha comprometido con importantes
anuncios en cambio climático acabar el
uso del carbón proteger especies y mares
para el 2030 también bajar las emisiones
para 2050 y hacer más inversiones en
infraestructura para así acortar la
influencia que está teniendo la china en
países en desarrollo de otro lado el
presidente yo vaivén terminó la primera
etapa de su gira por europa aquí en el
reino unido con una visita a una
audiencia privada con la reina isabel
posteriormente yo vaivén atenderá a la
cumbre de la otan mañana en bruselas en
mexica y este miércoles se reunirá en
suiza en ginebra con el presidente
vladimir putin intenta entonces yo
vaivén recuperar este terreno y esa
importancia de eeuu en el mundo
justo como lo mencionaba nuestra enviada
especial tras su estancia en cornualles
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
llegó a bruselas donde participará de la
cumbre de la otan donde se prevé que
reafirme el compromiso de su país con la
defensa y la seguridad colectivas
posteriormente el mandatario se reunirá
en ginebra suiza para con el presidente
ruso vladimir putin que más temprano se
refirió a lo que espera de esta reunión
me parece que ayudará a restablecer
nuestros contactos y las relaciones
establecer un diálogo directo crear un
mecanismo de acción que funcione en
aquellos ámbitos que son de interés
mutuo existen tales intereses la parte
estadounidense también habla de lo mismo
y en general estoy de acuerdo con ellos
en que efectivamente hay algunas
cuestiones de interés mutuo la
estabilidad estratégica los conflictos
regionales la preocupación por el medio
ambiente en un sentido global estas son
las cuestiones en las que realmente
podemos trabajar con eficacia sitio 9 en
nicaragua continúan las detenciones de
opositores al gobierno de daniel ortega
cuatro integrantes del partido unión
democrática renovadora fueron capturados
este domingo bajo la acusación de
incitar a la injerencia extranjera en
los asuntos internos y pedir
intervenciones militares ya son 12 los
disidentes arrestados entre ellos cuatro
candidatos presidenciales opositores
jorge hurtado tiene los detalles
la cacería de disidentes continuó en
nicaragua el gobierno que lidera daniel
ortega arrestó otros cinco opositores
entre ellos a dora maría téllez y hugo
torres
este último fue amigo cercano de ortega
y este vídeo antes de su arresto hace 46
años arriesgue la vida para sacar de la
cárcel a daniel ortega y a otros
compañeros presos políticos pero así la
vida así son las vueltas de la vida y lo
que una vez acogieron principios en
favor de la justicia en favor de la
libertad hoy lo han traicionado hoy son
sus principales enemigos de sus
principios desde inicios de junio han
sido arrestado cuatro opositores
precandidatos a la presidencia cristiana
chamorro juan sebastián chamorro arturo
cruz félix maradiaga y también el
empresario joxe agirre el ex canciller
josé palé y la activista opositora
violeta granera en paradero desconocido
los detenidos comparten una
característica ponen en peligro la
cuarta reelección de ortega como
presidente
daniel ortega gobierna nicaragua desde
2007 y se han parado en el argumento de
desestabilización política para
justificar la detención de los
opositores desde el esfera internacional
varias potencias y organizaciones han
pedido la liberación de los disidentes
amenazando con expulsar al país de la
oea en las calles la polarización es
evidente
y si se hagan unas elecciones libres
[Música]
debería pagar
el cargo que tenga a cinco meses de las
elecciones generales programadas para el
7 de noviembre de continuar estos restos
ortega y su partido serían los únicos en
participar
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
volvemos en breve con más noticias aquí
en france 24
[Música]